la función f está definida sobre los
números reales la siguiente tabla nos da
algunos valores de f ok tenemos aquí
algunos valores de x y sus
correspondientes valores cuando los
evaluamos en f entonces si x es igual a
menos 4.1 efe de x es menos 5 si nos
acercamos un poquito más al menos 4 con
menos 4.0 1 f x es menos 55 y así nos
seguimos pero lo que nos están
preguntando en este ejercicio es cuál es
una estimación razonable para el límite
cuando x tiende a menos 4 de fx así es
que pues tenemos que pensar en esto y
una buena forma de pensar en cuál es una
estimación razonable para un límite es
pensar en qué es lo que está pasando con
estos valores primero qué es lo que está
pasando con estos valores cuando nos
acercamos al -4 desde la izquierda
cuando tomamos valores más chicos que
menos 4 y nos vamos acercando cada
es más a menos 4 y eso es lo que tenemos
en esta parte de la tabla pero luego
también tenemos que pensar a que parece
que se acerca a esta función cuando nos
acercamos a menos 4 por la derecha
cuando tomamos valores más grandes que
menos 4 y nos acercamos cada vez más por
aquí tenemos los valores de fx cuando
nos aproximamos a menos 4 por la
izquierda y aquí tenemos los valores de
fx cuando nos aproximamos cada vez más a
menos 4 por la derecha pero veámoslo más
de cerca cuando x es menos 4.1 fx es
menos cinco cuando x es menos 4.01 fx es
menos 55 si x es menos 4.001 o sea
estamos a una milésima de llegar al
menos 4 f x es menos 555 y finalmente
cuando x es igual a menos 4
x es menos 5555 esto que estamos viendo
está muy interesante porque podría haber
varios escenarios por aquí cada que nos
acercamos cada vez más a -4 estos
valores aumentan cada vez más en un
escenario podría ser que estos valores
aumentarán muchísimo se fueran hacia
menos infinito pero justo en el valor
menos 4 la función hiciera un salto de
regreso al menos 5555 ese es un
escenario posible o también podría hacer
que estos valores aumentarán y
aumentarán pero no se fueran hacia menos
infinito sino que se acercarán cada vez
más a menos 5555 pero bueno por el
momento lo vamos a dejar en paz vamos a
ver qué pasa cuando nos aproximamos a -4
desde la derecha cuando x es igual a
menos 3.9 fx es 5 en x igual a menos
3.99 efe x 55 y en
efe de menos 3.999 fx es 555 lo que
estamos observando por acá es que
conforme x se acerca a menos 4 los
valores de fx se vuelven cada vez más
grandes en lugar de volverse cada vez
más negativos entonces como mencioné
anteriormente aquí solo podemos ver qué
escenarios se pueden presentar porque no
tenemos todos los valores de f no
podemos estar seguros porque en las
tablas sólo tenemos una muestra de los
valores en lugar de tener a todos los
números reales entonces vamos a dibujar
por acá cuáles son los escenarios que
podrían estar sucediendo repito no
podemos estar seguros de cuál es el
escenario que realmente está ocurriendo
porque solo tenemos una muestra de los
valores de f pero eso no importa porque
aquí nos están preguntando cuál es una
estimación razonable por aquí tenemos el
eje x
y este es el eje y lo que nos importa es
qué valor toma efe cuando x es igual a
menos 4 como estábamos diciendo hay
varios escenarios posibles entonces pues
vamos a empezar por uno vamos a empezar
por qué pasa cuando x se acerca a menos
4 por la izquierda conforme la x se
acerca cada vez más a menos 4 usando
valores menores que menos 4 efe tiene
dos posibilidades
efe puede acercarse cada vez más a menos
5555 y entonces podemos decir que por
acá este valor es menos 5555 o los
valores de fx pueden aumentar y seguir
aumentando e irse hacia menos infinito
pero vamos a empezar por este caso
también tenemos que considerar qué pasa
con los valores de f cuando nos
acercamos a menos 4 por la derecha lo
que estamos viendo por acá es que los
valores de f
aumentan cada vez más no sabemos si
aumentan hacia infinito o si se quedan
en algún lugar en medio lo que sí
sabemos es que no se están acercando
hacia el mismo valor hacia el que se
están acercando los valores menores que
menos 4 por lo que en esta situación no
tenemos un límite conforme x tiende a
menos 4 aunque la función esté definida
en menos 4 no existe el límite conforme
x tiende a menos 4 porque conforme nos
aproximamos por la derecha los valores
de f se van hacia infinito y conforme
nos aproximamos por la izquierda los
valores de f se van a menos 5555 ahora
otro escenario que podría estar
sucediendo con los valores menores que
menos 4 es que se vayan hacia menos
infinito pero justo en el valor x igual
a menos 4 la función salta y toma el
valor de menos 5555 vamos a borrar este
pedacito para que se vea mejor
así es que de ambos lados parece como
que tenemos una cinto está tenemos esta
asunto está vertical si nos acercamos
por la izquierda
efe se va a menos infinito y si nos
acercamos por la derecha efe se va hacia
infinito pero justo en el valor de x
menos 4
efe está definida como menos 5555 este
es otro de los escenarios pero en este
escenario tampoco existe el límite
conforme x tiende a menos 4 porque no
estamos aproximando al mismo valor
finito de los dos lados en esto de los
límites hay un detalle que confunde a
muchísimas personas podemos tener por
aquí nuestros ejes y tal vez tenemos una
función que en cierto valor si la
aproximamos por la izquierda se va a
infinito y si la aproximamos por la
derecha también se va hacia infinito de
todas formas no diríamos que existe ese
límite porque el límite tiene que ser un
valor finito al que estemos aproximando
de ambos lados pero bueno en todo
escenarios que vimos en este ejemplo no
existe el límite ya sea que la función
se vaya a menos infinito cuando se
acerca a menos 4 por la izquierda o se
aproxima cada vez más a menos 5555 de
todas formas no se aproxima al mismo
valor que cuando aproximamos a menos 4
por la derecha entonces el límite no
existe